Through the class project, you'll investigate New York
City subway ridership as a data scientist might. First,
you'll pull some publicly available data on subway ridership,
and also on New York weather conditions, using the
New York MTA website and the Weather Underground
API. Then, you'll answer some questions about subway ridership
using statistics and machine learning. Does the weather influence
how many people ride the subway? Is the subway
busier at certain times than others? Can we
predict subway ridership? Finally, you'll develop some charts
and graphics that communicate your findings, and synthesize
everything into a cohesive write-up that your friends
or family might find useful and informative. This
may sound daunting, but we'll be going through
this step by step, and learning how to use the necessary tools as we go along.